the match when actually the structural
racism that those players feel the
racism that they feel every day which is
why they take the knee before
the match and the team do that in
solidarity that was so
painfully borne out by the horrific
abuse of those three
young men who who took the penalty right
boris johnson on his feet now
may not have been the one we were all
hoping for i know that the
whole house will want to congratulate
gareth southgate
and the england squad for their
fantastic achievements
over the last month the nation is proud
of each
and every one of them mr speaker this
morning i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings
later today and this lot thank you very
much mr speaker
can i second the prime minister's
support for our outstanding
england team and players but perhaps say
that it's a pity it didn't come
sooner
we all know the importance of double
vaccination especially against the
delta or johnson variant of the virus
but
in but in harmony despite the hard work
of our local
nhs council and volunteers only 36
of adults have been double jabbed so
will the prime minister think again
before recklessly removing all barriers
to infection and transmission
on the 19th of january will he keep the
regulations on mark wearing
and like the mayor of london keep
fighting the virus until it's beat
[Applause]
mr speaker if we had followed the right
the honorable gentleman's
uh precepts uh who i remember of course
he campaigned
vehemently to stay in the european union
we would not have achieved
the fastest vaccine rollout of any
european country
and have vaccinated the highest
proportion of any uh of any european
population
uh mr speaker that is the that is the
reality and as for
as for his criticism of the of the road
map mr speaking i respectfully point out
to the
honorable gentleman the month is july
not january mr speaker
we now come to father of the house of
peter bottom
mr speaker it should be obvious that the
cabinet is as inclusive as the english
football team
and some of these criticisms i think are
misplaced
can i welcome mr speaker your words
tuesday's debate and the prime
minister's first paragraph
on the treasury minute from monday can
we agree
that a vote in this house does not
amend an act of parliament passed by
both houses
are we expecting a similar debate in
another place and can i suggest to the
prime minister
that instead of leaping from 0.5 to 0.7
at some stage in the future
we step towards it because the 40
increase in one year is ludicrous
and perhaps the chance to consider we're
going to 5.56 6.5 and then seven thank
you
i i thank the right horrible gentleman
to my honorable friend uh very much
for uh the the his opening point and
digest on
uh what uh on the on oda of course
uh he i can give him this reassurance we
will continue uh
to follow the law and he will have heard
clearly uh what
uh both my rival friend the chancellor
had to say from this dispatch box
and what i said as well we want to
return uh 2.7
as fast as we can when fiscal conditions
allow we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
thank you mr speaker can i start by
thanking the england football team
for everything they've given this
country over the last six weeks
i'm so proud of this young diverse and
humble
team and everything that it represents
mr speaker
they're the very best of modern britain
everything that i know this country
can be does the prime minister think
that it was wrong to criticize the
england team's decision
to oppose racism by taking the knee as
gesture politics i
i agree very much with what the right
honourable gentleman has said about
the england team and i repeat i want to
thank each and every one of them
uh for what they did uh their incredible
campaign they ran
in the in the euro 2020 uh championships
and they do represent
the very best of our country and i
repeat that i utterly condemn and abhor
the racist outpourings that we saw on
sunday night
and so what we're doing is today taking
practical
steps to ensure that the football
banning order regime
is changed so that if you are guilty mr
speaker of racist abuse on
line of footballs then you will not be
going to the match
no ifs no buts no exemptions and no
excuses
mr speaker i'm sorry that just won't
wash and it rings hollow
on the seventh remem remind the prime
minister in the house on the 7th of june
the prime minister spokesperson said
this
on taking the knee specifically the
prime minister is more focused on
actions
rather than gestures on the 14th of june
on the 14th of june the home secretary
said
the home secretary said i just don't
support
people participating in that type of
gesture politics
the conservative mp from basic law
called it a ridiculous
empty gesture so there's no point of
pretending
that these things weren't said the
england footballer
tyrone mings said that
labour party member i hear shouted out
is that really the response
is that tyrone ming's
tyrone ming said and the house might
want to listen
he said this labeling anti-racism
messages as gesture politics
served to stoke the fire of racism and
hatred prime minister powerful words
from someone who has himself been
subjected to racist
abuse he's right isn't he
mr speaker i want to reiterate our my
support our support our total support
for our fantastic england team and i i
support them in the way that they
uh they show solidarity with their
friends who who face racism mr speaker
but when he talks about
uh the home's secretary and letting me
just remind him that uh my right on
befriend the home secretary his face
racism and prejudice
or all her career and the kind that he
could never imagine and she has taken
practical steps to get black and
minority officers
into the police in record numbers in
fact
speaking i am sorry to interrupt you
i want to hear the prime minister if his
own side don't want to hear him i'm sure
the tea room will accommodate them
it's very important to listen to what
the prime minister's got to say have you
finished prime minister
are you okay yeah mr speaker let me
be clear i totally condemn all racism
including that directed at the home
secretary but she's got this
wrong the whole country knows it his own
mps know it
in the last few days everybody has seen
england's black players have been the
targets of disgusting racist abuse
following sunday's match disgusting and
this is really simple mr speaker
either the prime minister is with the
england players
in their stand against racism or he
could defend his own record
those of his ministers and some of his
mps but he can't have it both ways
so can he tell the house does he now
regret
failing to condemn those who booed
england players for standing up to
racism
yes or no
[Applause]
mr speaker we made it absolutely clear
that no one should boo
the england team and uh and mr speaker
what we're doing now is taking following
the following the racist abuse that
our players sadly suffered on sunday
night and and thereafter
we're taking practical action so in
addition to changing the football
uh banning order regime uh last night i
met representatives
representatives of facebook of twitter
of ticktock of snapchat
uh of instagram and i made it absolutely
uh clear to them that we will legislate
to address this problem mr speaker in
the online harms bill
and unless they get unless they get hate
and racism off their platforms they will
face
fines amounting to 10 of their global
revenues and we all know mr speaker
that they have the technology to do it
mr speaker the online harms bill's been
promised for three years i'm not sure
a 15-minute chat at a garden party moves
things forward that significantly
but i want to take the prime minister up
on what he said about being absolutely
clear because here
i have the headline mr speaker boris
johnson refuses to condemn
fans booing england taking the knee
that's the story
that's the headline june the 6th boris
johnson refuses to condemn fans booing
england
taking the new that's absolutely clear
it's not quite what the prime minister
is implying today
it quotes it goes on to quote the prime
minister spokesperson
saying that the prime minister fully
respects the rights of those who choose
to make their feelings known yeah it's
about booing
fully respects their rights and the home
secretary said that boeing was
a choice for them quite frankly so no
condemnation there no absolute clarity
there
mr speaker when
senior government ministers and
conservative mps defend the boeing
of an anti-racist message who do they
think they're defending prime minister
and why are they defending it
mr speaker nobody defends booing of the
england side
nobody defends boeing of the england
side and if he if he attacks
if he continues to attack the home
secretary
i want to hear the prime minister i want
to know the answer
and i expect the opposition to listen to
the answer
prime minister well thank you thank you
mr speaker we
we love and admire the england side of
what they did they represent the best of
our country
nobody don't nobody defends booing the
england side mr speaker but what the
home secretary has been trying to do
all her life is not just to fight racism
but to take practical
to take practical steps to advance the
cause
of black and minority ethnic groups
which he has done
successfully notably in the in the
police and and since mr speaker he's
he's chucking this kind of thing around
can i ask him now
to retract uh this this leaflet
produced by the labor party during the
battle and spend
a by-election which was condemned by his
own
mps as dog whistle racism mr speaker
mr speaker the prime minister isn't
isn't kidding anyone in this house he's
not
kidding the public and he's not even
kidding his own mps
let me quote let me quote the
conservative mp for plymouth moore view
conservative mp the painful truth says
the conservative mp for plymouth moore
view
is that tyrone mings is completely right
i am very uncomfortable he says with the
position we conservatives
are needlessly forcing ourselves into so
prime minister behind you they don't
believe you and neither do we
mr speaker i will mr speaker we can all
see what's happened here
the government has been trying to stoke
a culture war
and they've realized they're on the
wrong side and now they hope that
nobody's noticed
why else would a conservative mp boast
that he's not watching his own team why
else would another conservative mp said
might say that marcus rashford spends
too much time
playing politics when he's actually
trying to feed children that the
government won't
and why will the prime minister refuse
time and time again even now to condemn
those
who boo our players for staying standing
up against races
mr speaker what is it that this england
team
symbolizes that this conservative party
is
so afraid of yes
well mr speaker i think i think the high
school judge for themselves
uh the the quality of the question that
the last uh
the right honourable gentleman has has
just put this is uh this i think the
whole house is
united uh including our distinguished
members
uh from scotland uh by the way mr
speaker in admiration
of the england team and of every single
member of that squad
and what they did and we stick up for
them mr speaker and what we're doing is
taking practical steps
to fight racism uh changing the football
banning order
regime finding the online companies and
by the way we will use
more legislation if we have to just as
we use the threat of legislation mr
speaker to stop
the european super league and we will
get on we will get on
with delivering for the people of this
country we will get on with vaccinating
the people of this country while they
continue to
to vacillate we will continue to
immunize the people of this country
while they improvise and dart around and
mr speaker i don't want to i don't want
to
engage in a a political uh culture war
of any kind
i want to get on with delivering for the
people of this country
he simply wants to get on with dithering
he doesn't want to engage in a culture
war and point scoring
give me a break football footballs
footballs football's a game racism
isn't promised that's why many of us
have been involved in the charity show
racism the red card
for years but far from giving racism the
red card
the prime minister gave it the green
light and i'll tell you the worst kind
of gesture politics
mr speaker putting an england shirt on
over a shirt and tie
whilst not condemning those booing is
the worst kind of gesture
mr speaker i want to ask the prime
minister finally about the reported
amnesty for crimes committed
during the troubles in northern ireland
i worked in northern ireland
for six years with the policing board of
the police i've also prosecuted
terrorists as the director of public
prosecutions so i know
how difficult and how sensitive this is
but a blanket amnesty including for
terrorists
is plain wrong i was in northern ireland
last week
and it's absolutely clear that the
government's honesty is not supported
by the political parties in northern
ireland and it's not supported by
victims groups
last thursday i spoke to victims of
terrorism at the wave trauma center in
north belfast mr speaker they haven't
even been properly consulted on this
proposal
if things are to move forward in
northern ireland any discussion has to
start
with the victims politicians in london
can't simply draw a line under terrorism
and other crimes and then force it on
those most affected
the prime minister looks up so let him
look up and let him hear
because i want to quote julie hamilton
mr prime minister
her sister maxine was among the 21
people killed by the ira
in the birmingham pub bombings so that's
julie hamilton
prime minister she says tell me prime
minister
if one of your loved ones was blown up
beyond recognition
where you were only able to identify
your son or daughter by their
fingernails
would you be so quick to grant their
murderers
an amnesty and propose such obscene
legislation what does the primus have to
say
to julie and she's listening and other
victims like her
mr speaker i i think that the uh her
house will
acknowledge the suffering of victims
like julian there and their families
and of course nothing i sail
uh or can do now can in any way mitigate
her her loss and and that is
uh that is clear but it is also true
that the people of northern ireland
must if we possibly can allow them to
they must move
forwards now and uh he will know
uh that the proposals that are being
brought forward and the
house will hear about them in more
detail later on from my right-hand
friend
the secretary of state foreign that are
being brought forward are
are measured they are balanced and they
have a wide degree of support
i may say uh from former labour prime
ministers and former labour leaders who
i think are considerable more just more
distinction uh i may say than the
than the right honourable gentleman
opposite and
he will recall that it was under uh that
labour administration that
many uh terrorists were unfortunately
uh given effectively an amnesty and
they were allowed to escape the full
consequences of their crimes as he knows
very well and that was that is the
reality whilst the sad fact remains
that and this this is of course uh no
consolation
to uh people like julie but the sad fact
remains
that there are many members of the armed
services who continue to face the threat
of vexatious uh prosecutions uh well
into their
70s and 80s and later and we are finally
mr speaker bringing forward a solution
to this problem to enable the province
of northern ireland to draw a line
under the troubles to enable the people
of northern ireland to move forward and
i think someone with greater
statesmanship and clarity of vision
i would have seen that mr speaker and
given these proposals
a fair wind belt
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the
scandalous situation at wally's quarry
landfill
in my constituency with the noxious gas
emissions is i'm afraid continuing
uh today there's been no apology from
the operator red industries and no
credible explanation for the odor that
is blighting the lives and the health
of so many of my residents so what
assurances can the prime minister give
me today that every effort will be made
to speed up the works that have been
mandated by the environment agency
that we will get a deadline as to when
we can expect this awful situation to be
resolved
and that those responsible are held
fully to account
mr speaker i yield to no one in my
admiration for the environment agency
uh but in this case uh mr speaker i
thank my friend because they are not in
my view
uh sorting this problem out uh fast
enough i am fed up
uh with this being uh raised with me we
must stop the stink and i want the air
around wally's quarry to be
of alpine freshness uh before too long
ian blackford the smp leader thank you
mr speaker let me begin by
congratulating the england team for
reaching the final an incredible
achievement
but the tragedy of the tournament
was the undercurrent of racism that was
ultimately targeted at
three young men rashford sancho
and sacca mr speaker whenever there is
racism
it falls on all of us to face it down
and to call it out and it is shameful
that it took
until last night for the prime minister
to meet with the main
social media companies and finally wake
up to the fact
that those who publish and promote vile
racist online abuse need to be faced
down and sanctioned
so can the prime minister tell us
what sanctions he thinks would be
appropriate for someone who publishes
racist content and it's shocking even to
have to say this out loud
describing africans as flag waving
picking innies
with water melon smiles
minister mr speaker i've
commented uh many times about the uh
words that i've said in the past and and
i think the house uh
understands how i think the house
understands how you can you can
you can take things out of context mr
people what
what i what i i think people i think
people do understand that but what they
also understand
is that there is a a chance
now to hold these internet companies uh
to account and to make sure
that they face fines running to 10
of their global income if they fail to
take hate and
racism off their platforms to speak and
i hope actually that the scottish
national
nationalist party i will support it in
blackfood
you know still no contrition
still no apology and mr speaker
the truth is that the tory party doesn't
sanction those
who publish that kind of racist content
they promote them to be prime minister
the legacy of this prime minister's dog
whistling
has followed him into 10 downing street
and it is now
at the heart of this tory government as
the england international taiwan ming
has so powerfully stated
this government doesn't get to stoke the
fires of racism
and pretend to be disgusted when it
happens
they don't get to condemn the racism of
others but deny
that the racism that they have even
provoked
in march this uk government's own report
on racism the soul report said that
there was no
systemic problem in the uk i think the
england men's football team would beg to
differ
after the shocking racism on show over
the last week
does the prime minister still stand by
his government's belief
that systemic racism is not a problem
that exists in the united kingdom
mr speaker i do think that racism is a
problem in the united kingdom and i
believe it needs to be tackled and it
needs to be
stamped out with some of the means that
i've described this morning but when he
attacks uh our party my party mr speaker
i'm afraid he's got the
the wrong target this is that this is a
party that has not only had the first
ever
muslim uh secretary of state for health
night was former chancellor
of course but has had two female prime
ministers the most diverse
cabinet in the history of this country
the most diverse government
in the history of this country we are
the party if you're a young person
growing up in a black or ethnic minority
group in this country
we are the party that represent hope and
opportunity
that is the reality about the
conservative party today
truly boston thank you mr speaker
the uk is packed full of incredible
innovation-led businesses capable of
leading
entire industries not least in hartford
and stalford
where we are at the heart of the
innovation corridor
i know this government wants to ensure
the best possible access to venture
funding
over multiple rounds to catapult scale
up businesses full of potential
into world beating companies would the
prime minister meet with me
to discuss how we can best make venture
work for the scale-up community
and transform best some of our best
ideas into some of the world's
biggest businesses i i thank the
honorable alien she knows a lot about
what she's uh the subject that she
mentions
this is a fantastic opportunity for this
country because we do indeed produce
a great many tech breakthroughs and
we're looking very much at how to
uh make sure that we scale up uh fast
but don't
let her forget that as i speak there are
three countries in the world
and mr speaker that have scaled up tech
breakthroughs
to unicorns worth more than a billion a
hundred unicorns worth more than a
billion pounds only three countries have
a hundred unicorns
they are the united states of america
china and the united kingdom
for over seven years black hillary has
been calling for the gargantuan hs2
railway
to be treated as an england only project
so that wales gets our fair share
not a single inch of track will be in
wales
but we're footing the bill today the
welsh affairs committee backed our call
calling the uk government's
categorization of hs2 in relation to
wales as
unfair and biased will the prime
minister
today right this wrong respect the welsh
affair select committee and assure that
wales
like scotland receives our
fair share from hs2
normally i have a great deal of respect
and interest in what the honorable lady
uh says but actually in this case she's
she's missed what the government is
doing
uh for transport connectivity in uh in
wales and too well something about which
i know that she's as passionate as i am
look at what we're uh doing in the union
connectivity review with the
the a55 uh with the north wales uh
railway
corridor into uh into into to liverpool
and uh look at what we're look at the m4
mr speaker never let it be forgotten
uh that it was the welsh uh labor
government not her fault of course
because she
she's applied but it was the welsh labor
government
mr speaker that spent 144 million pounds
on a study
on a study and then didn't even do the
diversion
let's go to dr matthew offered matthew
thank you mr speaker the circumstances
of jewish burials around the world is a
sensitive and important issue to my
constituents
and as such to me in january 1942 the
nazis built two concentration camps on
british soil
on the island of aldeny conditions were
appalling with multiple deaths
however there are just 397 recorded
graves in order
to six point six percent of a total
population of six thousand
internees in 1961 the british delegation
undertook an inquiry into these
atrocities that occurred on ordinary
today i asked the prime minister to
authorize the release of all documents
and information residing in the archives
into those investigations so we know
what happened to thousands of people on
the island of albany during world war
ii to quote ellie weisel to forget the
dead will be akin to killing them again
minister my honourable friend makes an
excellent point about the victims on
alderney we must never forget the
suffering of those
uh who on the channel islands who who
suffered under the occupation
between 1940 and 1945 i'm told that the
documents in question
have been transferred to the national
archives
mr speaker but i will make sure that the
relevant
minister meets uh my honourable friend
to discuss the matter further
there are currently 800 000 students
self-isolating
and even after the reforms of the
bubbling system the government's
failure to get the delta variant under
control
means that infections rising over the
summer will mean that
the autumn term will be very severely
affected in our schools
if the jcvi says that it is safe and
appropriate for adolescents
to receive the vaccine will the prime
minister
promise that every single adolescent
will be
offered the vaccine over the summer and
parents given all the information they
need to make an informed decision
so that schools can return and not
continue to be affected by the bad
policy making of this government
and the failure to get the delta variant
under control
mr speaker the uh right the honourable
gentleman seems to
want us to relax our rules on
uh protecting people from coronavirus i
don't think that's the right thing
uh to do at this time on self-isolation
and uh he he also calls for uh us to go
against the
uh the the jcvi in
and that that is a matter mr speaker for
the jcbi
stephen krab thank you thank you mr
speaker
with the economy rebounding and a great
many
job vacancies currently available does
my right honourable friend agree that
there's a tremendous opportunity
emerging now to build a stronger british
labor market
post brexit and post covert and that we
need to help employers create jobs
with better pay more security more
opportunity for skills and
career progression isn't that one of the
keys for levelling up
and ending the blight of inward poverty
yes mr thing i thank my right honourable
friend and i know how much he cares
about him and that's one of the reasons
why
we're not only rolling out our massive
plan for for jobs but why i'm proud that
uh
under this government we've increased
the uh national living wage
uh to uh by record amount to eight
pounds 91 per hour
let's go to peter grant peter
thank you mr speaker the communities of
leslie
markinch petrucker thornton woodside
and east beams and my constituency are
all either losing or have already lost
to post offices
since 2019. in addition constituents in
copenhagen
windergates cadam methyl parkhaven and
metal hill
have all had the description of
temporary closures or relocations
and the post office decline wood is
currently closed until further notice
given in the post office is 100 owned by
his government
what exactly does it take for him to
admit that the trading model for the
post office
is not working for the people that rely
on its services
uh mr speaker the uh the treatment of
the post office
uh the masters and subpost masters uh in
the
in uh the recent uh computer
uh malfunction was i'm afraid appalling
and i've made that i've made that clear
when it comes to
uh protecting and supporting uh post
offices particularly rural post office
but i think is what he was
uh he was driving at uh this government
will do everything it can
to protect them let's go to angela
richardson
angela mr speaker
too noisy too much air pollution and too
much time
wasted sitting in traffic impacting
productivity
the a3 as it narrows through guildford
has been the cause of frustration for
decades
according to highways england there are
no more sticking plasters
which is why i'm calling for the a3 to
be tunneled under guilford
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that as we build back better
after the pandemic
investment into major road
infrastructure solutions
will be an important part of delivering
on the leveling up agenda
right across the whole country minister
i i thank you and i know the stretch of
road that she refers to
very well as i'm sure many members
across this house do
as well i would love to be able to click
my fingers and say that we could tunnel
under
uh under guildford uh all i can say is
term is to speak in all canada we will
certainly look at it
uh but uh the honourable member should
be in no doubt that we're spending
a record sums uh 27 billion pounds on
improving england strategic roads
probably 640 billion pounds
best biggest best ever package of
infrastructure investment in this
country
let's go to howard williams hello
thank you mr speaker many people are
against
the potential consequences of thrashing
english covet regulations
in a time fullest prime ministerial
crash attack
wales's regulations to be announced
today are expected to take a cautious
and measured approach
will the prime minister make it clear
that those visiting wales this summer
must stick to welsh laws and that's
uncovered regulations
he can only speak for england
prime minister yes of course mr speaker
and
i think that uh people should stick to
the
the rules and the guidance wherever they
are and i think he's absolutely right
to talk about a cautious and a measured
approach
john penrose uh mr speaker the prime
minister will have seen that two
recently published government
commission reports mined into
competition policy and the task force
on innovation growth and regulatory
reform both make the same
two recommendations to inject fresh
energy into our better regulation regime
so we can deliver our brexit ambition of
replacing ponderous eu regulations with
simpler digital and less burdensome uk
equivalents without reducing quality
standards in the process
so will he take this opportunity to
unleash
a big post-brexit better regulation
dividend by declaring his
enthusiastic support for a strong new
one-in-two out regime
with no loopholes or exceptions right
here today
yes mr speaker and i i think it is
obvious that the
the uk has a massive amount to gain uh
not just from his
uh report which i i much enjoyed as i as
i told him i thought was excellent
but also from the tigger uh report the
task force on
uh on reducing regulation and i thank
them for that and they'll be seen here
he
and they will be seeing a lot more in
the next few weeks let's go to john
nicholson john
thank you mr speaker sir yesterday at
the prime minister's instigation
333 conservative members of this house
including some of its wealthiest voted
to deprive some of the world's
poorest children of clean water
education for girls programs we
guarantee
will be slashed polio eradication
schemes too
most people go into politics to make the
world a better place but the prime
minister seems to be an exception
as he reads of the anguish his decision
has caused
and as the father of a young child
doesn't he feel
the merest hint of shame
mr speaker i think the people of this
entire country should be
immensely proud of what the uk is doing
abroad
uh whether it is educating uh millions
of girls
uh with an increase to support for
female education whether it's
helping the country uh countries around
the world to tackle climate change with
11.6
billion pounds uh of investment or
helping
uh refugees uh in yemen uh or syria or
ethiopia with 900 million pounds we're
spending 10
billion pounds a year uh on overseas
aid alone mr speaker to say nothing of
what we're doing with vaccines the whole
country
should be immensely proud of what the uk
is doing in spite
of this pandemic let's go to faye jones
faye thank you
mr speaker i'm sure you will know the
green man festival which is an
incredibly popular
international music event which takes
place in quick owl in my constituency
the festival organizers have gone to
great lengths to ensure the event is
covered secure
but the welsh government refuses to give
them the green light to go ahead as a
test event
unlike similar events in england so will
my right honourable friend help us by
giving the green man festival his full
support
and encourage the welsh government to
get behind the festival at long last
prime minister uh well mr speaker i
haven't been invited to attend the green
man festival but it sounds
it sounds it sounds great uh she's
obviously my older friends obviously
my friend's obviously a big fan um
i will do what i can to to pass her
message along i thank her for
campaigning for for wales and for the
green man festival the speaker
my constituent jackie davis was
diagnosed with a type of blood cancer in
april which prevents her immune system
from
developing antibodies against covid
jackie wants to live as normal a life as
possible
and to do everyday things like going
shopping but she's terrified
and she thinks that the rapid lifting of
restrictions on monday is putting her at
risk
with the delta about variant about to
spike due to the government's decision
to lift restrictions
particularly the requirement to wear
masks in public places
what's his message to people in jackie's
situation
will he rethink his reckless gamble of
lifting all these restrictions
on monday and yes jackie did support
stan in the eu
well my my message to to i'm i'm sorry
obviously for the
condition that uh that jackie suffers
and
uh i think that the the labour party uh
obviously needs to to work out whether
it's in favor of going ahead uh with
step four or not because it's not it's
not at all clear
uh from what he has said uh or what uh
the right honourable gentleman the
leader of the opposition
has said they don't they don't have a
clue uh mr speaker but what i can say to
him
is that we expect and recommend we
expect and recommend
everybody i say to jackie we expect to
recommend everybody
uh to wear a face covering uh in a
confined space
where you're meeting people you don't
normally meet and uh that is that is
quite right
final question thank you mr speaker
last week i met with the reading agency
that is about to launch its annual
summer reading challenge and hopes to
reach a million
children primary school children this
year what a great excuse to go to one of
our brilliant libraries
and take part in the covert education
catch-up with this in mind would my
writer-in-law friend
join me in encouraging every child
across the nation
to take part in the summer reading
challenge pick up a book
and read back better yeah
i i thank my she's quite right and i
could there couldn't be a better
campaign
uh for the summer we put uh 1.9
million of support into into the reading
scheme that she mentions but
of course there's 200 million uh going
into the holidays activities fund
and there couldn't be a better more
useful happier way
of occupying your time on holiday than
by reading a good book mr speaker
can i just gently say to all leaders
that
in the end i've had to cut off quite a
few benches because the amount of time
that's been taken up at the beginning
can we think about those as well
it's so important that they get their
questions
there's no punch forwarder i'm now
suspending the house for three minutes
to enable necessary arrangements for the
next business spread order
well that was prime minister's questions
we'll be going back to the commons in a
moment there's going to be an urgent
question
uh from nick thomas simmons to pretty
patel on racist abuse on social media
but let's uh just go over a prime
minister's question should say a little
bit of breaking news sean berry
the other co-leader of the green party
has said she won't be standing for
re-election
either uh when it comes to that contest
in the autumn so there'll be two
there'll be new leaders of
the green party appointed but beth let's
talk about those exchanges focusing on
racism what's been said and quite
difficult
for boris johnson it was difficult for
boris johnson you can tell when he's
finding it difficult because he
actually gets quite angry and irritated
and quite aggressive and that was his
response after he was pressed repeatedly
about this mixed messaging from
government ministers
in the run-up to all of those games and
not the run-up to the
england italy final in which they were
asked again about
fans uh booing the players and they
simply did not outright
condem it and there are quotes
on the record of ministers not doing
that uh
not condemning the booing uh and boris
johnson
uh defended pretty patel because you
remember she said i've got it here
she said that it was a choice for them
quite frankly if they wanted to
boo the england team and boris johnson
got quite angry about this when
kirsten would put it to him saying that
priti patel has suffered racism all her
life in a way that
kirstama couldn't even begin to imagine
and
the prime minister went on to say that
they did condemn the
the government did condemn uh booing but
of course there is a record
of mixed messaging which left kierstama
to finish that exchange basically
accusing the prime minister of giving
a green light to racism instead of
giving it as he said a red card so
i think it was uncomfortable uh and then
ian blackford going a step further and
actually
raising what the prime minister's
written in his previous career yeah he
he talked about
there's a series of uh articles that
boris johnson wrote when he was a
journalist making
uh comments racist comments and uh
what people found very offensive i mean
there was the issue of
he talked about the water melon smiles
that was
referred to by ian blackford there was
also of course
the issue of when he did a column about
muslim women looking like
letterboxes for uh wearing uh veils
um so there's a there's a record uh
for boris johnson on this um and that
was raised again today and i think it
was quite uncomfortable for him
what else any any other important issues
i mean just at the end there
an issue that's going to come up in the
commons of this um
amnesty proposed for people involved in
the northern ireland troubles
yeah that's right there's um ministers
expected to
introduce a statue of limitations to end
all prosecutions related
to the troubles before 1998 and brandon
lewis and northern ireland secretary
will say that's because they don't want
northern ireland to be hamstrung by the
past but kierstarma
raising that making it clear
that labour have questions about it as i
understand that they are going to oppose
this on the basis that they think that
people
should have to face justice that there
was an agreement
uh when installment was uh re
uh what was what's the worst when it was
restarted that
the troubles would be addressed and that
there would be
justice for families and there would be
prosecutions for both paramilitaries and
soldiers the government now rowing back
on that and i think labour will
oppose that and say that they think uh
that those historical prosecutions
should go ahead and of course kirsten
i'm a former prosecutor exactly yeah
well we can and go back i think uh to
the comments now where
we are expecting that urgent question
from nick thomas simmons to pretty patel
uh on the prevalence of racial abuse on
social media that is going to be
followed by what we were just talking
about there
uh from uh the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis
his statement on what's been called the
legacy of new lands past and then
a third statement uh is going to follow
a second statement rather a third
a piece of parliamentary business is
going to follow from grant shaps he's
going to talk about
uh transport decarbonization
uh and interesting beth really that you
know although this is a vital issue for
the government
particularly with the cop 26 conference
in november
not really arousing any interest from
mps or indeed the prime minister
well at the moment the government is so
focused on
on managing the covid wave that is
is coming upon us but when we get to the
autumn the issue of
climate change and the environment uh
we'll be back on the agenda not least
because the government
are going to be hosting cop the big
global
summit in november in glasgow
and the prime minister is going to want
to be seen as a global leader
on this he didn't get that far in the g7
with getting people to sign up to
commitments and indeed one of the
reasons that alok sharma
the minister in charge of cop is
opposed to the foreign budget aid
cuts is because he thinks it makes it
hard for countries to sign up
well as i say that statement later but
let's go now to this urgent question
from nick thomas simmons to principal
speaker for his question i'm going to
take a moment if i may
to reflect on the extraordinary success
of the england football team in this
tournament knowing as we do that
uh the background to the uh urgent
question
that team played their hearts out for us
and they won this uh speaking now is
victoria atkins the
home office minister pretty patel not
responding to the questions
and with dignity they brought our
country together
and they united us in joy
it is therefore a great shame that the
success and achievements of
every member of that team has been
overshadowed by the racism of online
trolls
the prime minister has just in prime
minister's questions reinforced our
collective condemnation
of racism online and offline
individuals who commit racist offenses
should face the full
force of the law and we already have
robust legislation in place
to deal with online hate but governments
around the world are grappling with how
we collectively
tame the wild west of the internet
we are leading the world in tackling
online harms
in the introduction of the online safety
bill
it will put in places it put in place
measures to tackle
illegal and legal but harmful abuse
including racist abuse if major
platforms do not meet their own
standards to keep people safe
and address abuse quickly and
effectively they could face enforcement
action let one message ring loud and
clear
to those companies there is no reason
for companies to wait
until the regime is fully running to
take action
against this abhorrent abuse indeed such
delays
i suspect mr speaker will serve just
to stiffen the resolve of the government
and indeed of this house
in addition to this we have asked the
law commission to conduct a wide-ranging
review
into hate crime including offensive
online communications let's put this in
context in 2019 to 2020
the police recorded more than 76 000
race hate crimes increases in police
recorded crime
hate crime in recent years have been
driven by improvements in crime
recording
and better identification of what
constitutes a hate crime
while statistics can help us track
trends
we must of course always remember that
behind the numbers
are real people who are often left
traumatized
and shaken by their experiences there is
nothing
so damaging so corrosive about the
impact that racism has
both on victims and on our communities
more widely and so i'd like to conclude
this statement with the words
of our england captain gareth southgate
we have been a beacon of light in
bringing people together
the national team stands for everybody
and so that togetherness has to continue
we have shown
the power our country has when it does
come together
mr speaker let us all live up to those
words
oh call nick thomas i'm grateful for
that response but the
reaction of this government has lacked
urgency and completely failed to
understand the scale of the revulsion
that exists as a result of the events of
recent days
the england men's football players have
been a credit to the country on and off
the pitch
and when they took the knee to stand
against racism this was
not gesture politics they spoke
courageously
to a desire for change across our
country
and the failure of the prime minister
and the home secretary
to condemn those who were booing the
tame taking the knee
was shameful and it frankly makes their
later protestations of support for the
team
no more than empty words and the home
secretary hasn't even bothered to turn
up to answer this question
today the racist abuse
to which marcus rashford jaden sancho
and bakayo sacco have been subjected is
disgraceful
and such behavior has been too common on
social media for too long
social media platforms have had more
than long enough to act
the home secretary said to me on monday
the legislation will be absolutely
pivotal
but the government has dragged its feet
on bringing the online harms bill
forward
worse still the bill is currently
proposed will
not address what we've seen in the last
couple of days
allowing social media companies to set
their own
terms and conditions will not be enough
would the government therefore commit
to including criminal sanctions for
senior ex
senior executives in that bill and in
addition
will the minister tell us exactly when
the government will be exceeding to the
demand
on these benches to extend football
banning orders
to offenses that take place online as
was promised by the prime minister
in prime minister's questions and
finally
will the prime minister and the home
secretary finally show some leadership
and apologize
for siding with those who are booing and
not with the brave england players
mr speaker i if i may just explain to
the house where the home secretary is
today she is at this very moment
hosting a long-standing meeting
with charities who are on the front line
of tackling
victims of tackling violence against
women and girls and survivors of those
crimes
and so i hope the house will instead put
up with me
in order to answer this urgent question
but i know
that the home secretary would reject
many of the indeed all of the
allegations that the honourable
gentleman has just made
about her conduct she has been
relentless she has been relentless in
pursuing
social media companies to ensure that
they take
a much tougher stances as we all expect
not in just not just in relation to um
racism online but also child sexual
exploitation and terrorism
and other offences and so i do not
accept
his accusations across the dispatch box
in terms of the online safety bill this
is a landmark piece of legislation
the government has been very very
careful to ensure
that this bill a receives the scrutiny
of the house that is why we are taking
uh the confidence step i would say of
opening the draft bill up to
pre-legislative scrutiny we
don't do that for every bill but we want
to get this bill right the house will
remember we did exactly the same with
the domestic abuse
bill and uh the bill was made all the
better for it
and so i'm delighted that labour have
provided now i understand the names for
their committee
members uh so that the pre-legislative
scrutiny can take place
at pace but i underline the message that
this house but also
the public are watching the behaviors of
online companies very carefully
and any company would be very wise to
set out what it plans to do in relation
to meeting the expectations of
this place and the public when it comes
to conducting
their systems in a way that is clear and
that
prevents the sorts of abuse we have seen
this weekend
in terms of football banning orders
again the honourable gentleman will
gentlemen forgive me would have
heard the prime minister say very
clearly at pmqs
about the work that the government is
conducting in relation to football
banning orders
it is complex because we know for
example some of the trolls
that have targeted some members of the
team
over the weekend are overseas
but we want very much to work with
football clubs and others to ensure that
these orders have the powers that we
all want them to have and as i have said
throughout and this is the golden thread
that runs throughout our work
on tackling online crimes what is
illegal
offline is illegal online and that
is the principle we will be um adopting
throughout the online safety bill
thank you mr speaker i thank my
honorable friend for a statement and for
calling out some of the
vile racist abuse that our brilliant
players have
had to face on sunday night the center
for countering digital hate
identified and reported 105 instagram
accounts which racially abused members
of the england football team as of this
morning only six of them have been taken
down
so whilst we're getting warm words from
some of these social media companies
that appears to be all we're getting
from them at present
can my friend my honourable friend
therefore confirmed that the online
safety bill will be brought forward with
speed and that those who post this abuse
online will be held to
proper account i'm extremely grateful
indeed my honourable friend highlights
um
some of the the very practical responses
that social media companies can take
right now uh they don't need to wait for
the online safety bill
i read with some uh dismay and anger a
report in the i
paper today about how instagram had
applied its own rules
uh community rules uh in relation to
offensive emojis that were sent
to players and indeed highly offensive
words now the social media companies
themselves have to explain
what how exactly their community rules
accord with the expectations and indeed
the law
of our country but may i just make this
point again
we are not alone in this this is a
challenge
facing every democratic society in the
world
and it is by working together as we are
doing with our voluntary principles on
tackling
uh terrorism and child sexual
exploitation that is how we're going to
be able to make real progress
against these companies and against this
hatred we now go to smp spokesperson
stuart c mcdonald stuart
thank you mr speaker the disgusting
online racism faced by england players
is unfortunately overshadowing a
fantastic tournament and a fantastic
performance by an england team that has
rightly attracted admiration and perhaps
even a little bit of envy
so yes we urgently need stronger online
regulation content must be taken down
faster
and platforms can no longer be allowed
to support racist content
through shamefully lacks rules and we
need a debate on how we identify and
punish those peddling this hate
i will should agree that social media
regulation is not a silver bullet
online racism reflects offline racism
and the government needs to take
tackling racism including structural and
institutional racism
more seriously mr speaker whatever our
disagreements no one could say that the
previous prime minister didn't take
tackling racism incredibly seriously
why do we struggle to say the same about
the current prime minister
isn't it because on his watch too many
in his party have spent more time
downplaying racism than tackling it
and more time ridiculing anti-racism
campaigners and going after those who
actually peddle
racism so yes we will support action to
clamp down on online platforms
but will she support a change in
attitude in her party
again i i i thank the uncle gentleman
for his question and i
i can assure him that had scotland
reached the same dizzy heights as
england i'd have been
cheering them on um with the great
passion and strength of feeling so i'm
pleased that he is able to concede
um some uh support for the england team
um
in terms of his wider question about uh
racism and uh hate speech uh across
society
he is right to um acknowledge that this
is
um a matter for us all to tackle and he
will
know uh as sitting on the the home first
select committees he does
the um work that the government is doing
to tackle hate speech and
hate crimes of course hate crimes is a
very wide term it includes
not simply racism but also hatred
towards dis
disabled people towards uh transgender
people and so on and so that's why we
have asked the
law commission to look at online crimes
to make sure that they're
up to date and meet our expectations but
the wider message i think on
racism more generally is actually i have
been overwhelmed by the
public's response to these trolls over
the weekend if we look at what happened
to the mural in whittington for example
and how the public responded
how angry they were that some individual
had
defaced uh the mural in whittington and
how
positive um the public's reaction has
that to that has been
i think that is what we need to very
much uh reflect
reflect on and act on and indeed that's
why i quoted
um our captain because i think he has
summed up where the public and where we
are on this
and it is by working together that we're
going to tackle some of these hateful
hateful attitudes
well good luck thank you mr speaker
i know that the home secretary herself
has been at the receiving end of
terrible
racist abuse so will the minister agree
with me
that fighting racism online and in any
other form is a priority for her
and for the government and does she also
agree that this fight is mostly
effective
when racism and anti-racism campaigns
are fully understood by everyone and
that what
really matters is when meaningful action
is taken to tackle the scourge that
racism is
yeah yeah very much so and
the home secretary like other members
across this house
and we know sadly that women in
particular
women of color are targeted it seems by
online trolls um there are many many
people
in our society who have to deal with
this racism both online
but also sadly offline and so um
i think part of the part of our national
conversation
should be how we can each of us show
our complete support for the
campaigns to combat racism and to ensure
that we are doing everything we can both
individually but
as a country to tackle racist behavior
uh i know the home secretary feels very
strongly about this and indeed
home office minister victoria atkins
continuing to ask questions on racist
abuse
on social media pretty patel uh
electing to send her in rather than to
attend
the session herself and while that was
going on greater manchester police have
announced that they have arrested a
suspect age 37.
uh on a suspicion of defense under the
malicious communications act thank you
and he is now in custody
uh well a lot of business today in the
house of commons we will continue to
follow that
here on sky news uh my colleague
uh sarah hewson are taking over at one
o'clock stay with us
repeatedly over the last few days they
have told me this morning
that using some of those emojis as
racist slurs is against their rules yet
inexplicably they are still up and it is
still taking them
days to remove these posts speed matters
can the minister tell me what the online
safety bill is actually going to do
to take action on this speed issue and
to penalize companies for not moving
fast enough
because at the moment it looks as though
that action
won't happen that's unacceptable
keyboard cowards are being given a
megaphone
by these social media companies and it
has to stop
well i completely agree with right
honourable lady uh and chair of home
affair select committee
it is i don't think these internet these
tech companies quite understand the
anger and frustration
of everyone involved in trying to
scrutinize and to hold these companies
to account
when they come back at us with it
doesn't meet our community rules
words such as the words i suspect she is
thinking about
the emojis the language this is
unacceptable
in any civilized society and that
includes
online um for as well as
offline and so this bill is a real
opportunity for the government a to lay
the law down but also
as i say for parliamentarians across the
house to make their views known
i have long urged the companies to
listen carefully to members of
parliament in this place
and i would urge them again to do so
because if they don't listen
we will act
thank you mr speaker as someone who
represents one of the most diverse
constituencies
in the entire country can i put on the
record
how abhorrent racism is of
any form does my honorable friend agree
with me
that many of these online trolls
hide behind the cloak of anonymity
can she confirm that the police can
still
prosecute anonymous post postings
and will she consider whether we should
outlaw online posting because i do
think people would take more personal
responsibility
if it were in their own names
well the honourable lady lights upon
a very um important point but also
actually one that will require the
scrutiny the debate of this house
because whilst we know that
many many cowards hide behind anonymous
accounts
there are people who use their anonymity
legitimately so for example victims of
domestic abuse and indeed
whistleblowers in um very very
restrictive regimes overseas
so i know that this place when we come
to scrutinize this bill
will weigh that those arguments up very
very carefully
but again i i do have great sympathy
with her
viewpoint that if people are able to
hide behind these accounts
anonymously then of course it makes it
much more difficult for the police
to trace them and so again this is we
we need to think through i think as um
collectively
where we are prepared to draw the
boundaries uh
in the wild west of the internet we now
come to soros
thank you mr speaker the minister gave
the usual tory platitudes
yes she condemned the horrific racism
our england stars have faced
but what was she think about the prime
minister when he was doing
um well when he was describing black
people as piccaninnies with watermelon
smiles
when he used newspaper columns to mock
muslim women
as letterboxes and bank robbers when he
refused to condemn the billing of
england players taking the knee
and when his home secretary derided the
act anti-racist message as gesture
politics
isn't it the case mr speaker like
england star tyrone wings has said that
the home secretary
and the prime minister were stoking the
fire of racism
giving the green light to racism and
only now
when the consequences are clear are they
feigning
outrage
well mr speaker i i had hoped that we
were going to be able to conduct
this debate in a measured and collective
way
i don't genuinely think the honourable
lady is accusing either the prime
minister of this country or indeed the
home secretary
of racism that would be a truly
extraordinary allegation to make
but i hope at some point we will be able
to work together to tackle racism
that is what we all want to do that is
what the work of this government
is directed towards and i hope that
we're able to just lower the tone a
little bit and understand
that in that in again she's trying to
shout at me
again that in tackling these horrific
instances of racism we need to work
collectively together and and shouting
at me
across the dispatch box is not going to
help with that let's go to damian
collins damien
uh thank you mr speaker my honorable
friend agreed with me that the
incidence of racism on social media over
the last few days shows why the approach
taken in the draft online safety bill is
right
that we need an independent regulator
that will hold the companies to account
they've failed to take down this abuse
even though it's against their platform
policies
they've failed to take it down when
people have complained about it and
worse than that
their own recommendation tools were
actually promoting the content on sunday
night this has to stop
and it'll only stop when there's
independent regulation of these
companies
i'm very grateful to my little friend he
is he is absolutely right
in um his description of this bill as
being
necessary and required as i said i think
in
10 15 years time we will look back on
this era of the internet
and we will with the regulations in
place we will be in a much better place
in terms of people being able to
access uh social media and so on in a
positive
uh healthy way rather than having to put
up with this hatred
that we have seen in some quarters but i
also would emphasize that with the bill
um we have as part of imposing this duty
of care
we are proposing um fines on the
companies concerned of up to 18 million
pounds or
importantly up to 10 percent of
qualifying annual turnover
i suspect that that second figure may be
the figure that helps to concentrate
minds
let's go to jeremy corbyn jeremy
thank you mr speaker isn't the issue
that the government has refused to take
any action towards ending social media
discrimination of any kind
this in turn has found found the flames
of divisiveness and hate in our
communities
that we're currently witnessing as my
friend the member for coventry south
has just pointed out the amnesty
international report on toxic twitter
pointed out that black women are 84
more likely to experience racist abuse
online than anyone else
so the question to the minister is quite
simply this what
real steps is she going to take urgently
to ensure that no one and i mean
absolutely no one is able to post any
racist abuse
online at all
mr speaker i suspect i'm not the only
person
who um has felt a little bit astonished
that it is this right honourable member
who's chosen to ask that question about
taking
immediate action to tackle racism i
remain i remind
the house of the um findings of the
equalities and human rights commission
under his watch labour has unlawfully
discriminated against
harassed or victimized people because
they are jewish
and i am also reminded that a jewish
female
mp had to have police protection
at his party conference because of fears
of her own
safety so i will listen to many many
people
about tackling racism i will work with
pretty much anyone
but i must say i will take a long spoon
in which to suck with this particular
member
[Music]
let's just go to caroline notes caroline
mr speaker it is popular to blame mutant
algorithms for many things
but social media giants could use
algorithms to quickly and effectively
shut down accounts spouting racist bile
please can my honourable friend assure
me that the government is prepared to
take action against platforms like
instagram
who've been painfully slow to respond to
the horrific race
of racist abuse targeted of black
players since sunday
indeed and and again my honourable
friend my writing friend is
uh a lights upon a very very important
point that this
this power is already within uh the
reach of internet companies uh they seem
to think that their community rules
somehow take precedence over the laws of
our country and i can only imagine it's
uh the same across other countries uh in
the world so
the message to those tech companies is
that please
listen to the public's outrage actually
at some of these posts that are
festering on
your platforms and deal with them it is
simply
not acceptable to expect players or
victims of
this abuse to deal with it themselves
these
tech companies have the algorithms they
have the powers i've no doubt
in order to intervene and they should
use them now
let's go today margaret hodge margaret
thank you mr speaker my question is
similar but the racist abuse
which was targeted at the black
footballers has been absolutely
abhorrent and the tech giants could have
stopped it
but they chose not to because it suits
their business
model in october 2020 mark zuckerberg
decided literally on a whim to remove
holocaust denial from his facebook and
he did that
in february 2021 instagram after a
public outcry
made a u-turn changed their policy and
started to regulate some direct messages
of racial abuse
so does the minister agree with me that
it's not the powers
or the capability of the tech giants
that is lacking
but the will everybody knew the wembley
final
could result in a torrent of use yet the
online platforms
chose not to plan not to monitor not to
act
and does she further agree with me that
if we're to turn
empty rhetoric into action it's not
enough to
find the companies but the government
must legislate
to hold the senior executives to
personal account
and personal liability be personally
liable
for failing to remove harmful content
from their platforms
i'm extremely grateful and mindful of
the
uh own experiences that the right
honorable lady has had in terms of
abuse online and offline and i agree
with her that
of course that uh these powers exist
already and so
one can only conclude in the cases that
have been highlighted both
in this chamber and in newspapers that
uh the business is concerned do not wish
to remove
those items i've no doubt if i'm wrong
that they will correct me
um but there must be a will there and i
i very much hope
that a former member of this house uh
one sir nick clegg
who as we know advises facebook at a
very senior level in
california i very much hope he is
advising facebook as to the powers of
this place
and the anger that members across this
chamber are feeling
because uh it seems to me being
responding to these concerns makes not
just
good moral sense but also good business
sense
steven mike thank you mr speaker uh the
abuse we saw
after england's heroic final euro game
is beyond
disgusting and has no place in any way
we're just going to leave our coverage
from the commons there or that